right I hope you hope so welcome back to
game Sports coverage of e3 2014 we are
live right here at the Samsung booth and
it's ticking along we've got a bunch of
games we've already show we got a bunch
more to show today Arthur tell-tale
jonesing so travelers are judging by
your t-shirt
I wonder what type of video game we're
gonna see now why is Batman on the moon
Lego Batman 3 beyond Gotham so it's it's
it's the the next iteration of Lego
Batman franchise Batman is on the moon
because you know we've we've been to
Gotham we've we've we've been all round
there in Lego Batman 1 and 2 and we
wanted to go somewhere new and exciting
so where better to go than space I
remember at the end of Lego Batman 2
there was a heavy alluded allusion to
the idea of a third game you guys are
coming out you're coming out and it
seems like every platform under the Sun
for folks who might not have played
those previous two games or maybe played
the first one and drop down on the
second one and what are you guys doing
in the third game to sort of
reinvigorated I thought because the
third game is a tough one to do well
yeah well for us it's it's a really
exciting one to do because we're getting
to go back to a franchise we absolutely
adore so for us we wanted to go back and
it's like a term we've got in the office
it's a like a lego revolution it's a
lego luciene we want everything to be
new Ana Clara Lucia
leg Ellucian ditto the levels level loot
as well any Lego LEvolution they could
fit here but yeah we wanted to do
everything new so what we're doing is
we've got new suits we've got new modes
new characters you know this this is
going to have like more characters than
we've ever seen in a Lego Batman game
yeah we've got over 150 characters like
we've gone right through the whole DC
sort of like universe looking for
characters you're quite a lot in the
last game we did launches like but yeah
in this one it's it's all the characters
so we're going to go out to the lantern
world we're going out in the story
obviously Brainiac like you say at the
end of like a bat went to he rocks up
and he'd identified where Green Lantern
was so straight off the bat we're going
to give character the player just drop
in Lego Batman - spoilers on my face yes
yes oh yeah what we're going to be doing
is we straight away we're going to be
giving players access to
to the lego Justice League characters so
you're going to be able to play all of
your favorite characters but as well as
that the Legion of Doom come in okay and
right away we're going to be going right
you're going to get to play a mix and
match these characters together against
Brainiac and then all of a sudden with a
huge twist in the story you're off
around the lantern worlds and you're
going to go and visit some some places
that have never been seen in a video
game so for us it's it's really exciting
to go and explore and go around these
worlds excellent as a fan of the series
I've got a bunch of questions but if you
guys at home have any questions at
Daniel Dwyer on Twitter and make sure
I'll send them to Arthur here can we and
I want to ask you first the open world
stuff is really interesting the last
game yep same sort of setup is it an
open sort of world for you to pick the
levels as you want and I find
interesting stuff in it and if so is it
bigger than last summer end well what
we're doing is you know we want Lego
Batman 3 to be like they're likely at
the ultimate superhero game for the
whole family this year and we've gone
from Lego Batman 2 with the open-world
Gotham because we're going to space and
because of something that happens in the
story that I can't say what we've done
is we've evolved things and we're going
to give players the ability to explore
the lanten worlds yeah we've things that
we've done we can joke is amazing is it
the things that we've done before we're
trying to just go further with different
things and I think when people get to
play it they will really enjoy what
we've done this time around willed to be
any open-world Gotham in this one
because part of me really wants to do a
graphical like side-by-side between this
and Arkham Knight we do actually visit
Gotham in the story but like I say
there's something that happens which is
like it's so awesome and I can't really
show pretty further into it without
spoiling it yeah I don't wanna drop
spoilers too much yeah and so let's talk
about what's happening here what stage
of the game is this and what's going on
okay yeah so this the stuff that's been
going on on screen is again because
everything is new we're going into space
so we've got a load of this like like
kind of retro sort of like shooter stuff
stuff I grew up with as a kid
which gives us a new way of mixing some
gameplay in there um this this level is
part of the story yes like she's going
to need a bigger spaceship right um this
part of the story what we've got is
the Legion of Doom have taken over the
watchtower
they've Batman and Robin have been
called up to space with the rest of the
Justice League and the idea is they've
got to kind of break in and sort out the
Legion of Doom and this is kind of a
precursor to where Brainiac comes in in
the story so what we're doing here is
you can see Batman and Robin have got
like this whole new gadget wheel that
enables really really quick select
movement between suits they've also got
suits they're all new and exciting so
we've got a couple of fan favorites from
from Batman one and two and then a whole
load of new exciting suits because we
want to give people new excite you has
to do as well as it gave you got someone
like toy wonder who you know some people
be like what what is that it's like we
listen it's a real character but Robin
can basically get so I wonder out and
control him and he he has his own unique
abilities this is all about
characterization yeah we've got
obviously cyborg now cyborgs evolved
from the first game this time round
again he's got a whole load of new suits
some of these suits you've got him what
better way to hide from people than a
washing machine so yeah no one's going
to like think wow there's a washing
machine yeah this is known there as well
he can transform into a big big cyborg
they can run around you can smash stuff
up every character is is like brought to
life in a whole new way from what we've
done in the past you know some of the
characters that we've got as well you
know we're not revealing too many right
now but there are characters we've got
here you can see so we've got a couple
of the big Lego figures we've got Killer
Croc we've got Solomon grunts Solomon
Grundy's brilliant kill and Crocs
brilliant and as well as that there's a
couple of characters that adds the
animation on that the guys in the office
have done a fabulous job on these
characters but yet so as well you can
see a couple of characters - they're
where we've got bat-mite who a lot of
people might kind of quite like bat-mite
he's he's alike he's the ultimate Batman
fanboy right so we've got bat-mite
there's also Plastic Man so Plastic Man
here he can obviously bend and stretch
but he can try to film into some crazy
stuff so you know you can transform him
into like a retro 80s kind of space
hopper he can bounce around and do some
mad stuff and then as you as well flash
faster than ever he's got his unique
moves and you can also we've also got
please
so please is one of the red lanterns and
that's kind of like alluding to where
we're going with this game and what
we'll see and so travelers tales have
been working on these games for is it
over a decade maybe at this stage is it
close to it maybe it may well be yeah
but we now live in a post Lego the movie
world where like this type of humor and
what you guys have been doing for a long
long time now has a sort of a wider
global appeal for people who might live
outside of the the sort of them
videogames world yeah does that change
the way you in which you guys design
these games or like try and make these
characters no no yeah you think it'll
help actually you think people will
watch yeah I hope so yeah you know what
yeah well you got to remember is like
the lego video game franchise it's
hugely popular we're you know there's
over 100 million units of our game
shipped it's amazing and so for us if
that brings more people in we just love
to have fun and we love to make fun and
ultimately where if people pick these
games up buy them and enjoy them it's
our jobs done yeah we have so much fun
making them bringing characters to life
whether it is Joker whether it is
Solomon Grundy yeah whether it is Batman
and you know getting that interplay
between him and Robin and Alfred and yo
it's all about getting those
characteristics you know really sort of
like getting everything that makes those
characters great and throwing on the
screen with a brilliant script you know
the script in this onee far outweighs
like - for me I I think it's brilliant
I'm that sort of knows Virginia Perez is
asking and any famous voiceover actors
for this game or you guess but I can't
say yeah we have such an amazing cast
like we've been doing voice recordings
and yeah I'm sat there the other end of
the phone dialing in and and giving
direction and stuff and and I'm like I
can't believe he's on the phone it's
like and you're having fun and these
guys are reading the script and you just
hear them burst out laughing yeah we
have to extend the sessions cuz they
just they're having fun reading stuff
and yeah yeah obviously down the line
we'll announce and we've no other clues
my lips are sealed I know I I I would be
in so much trouble yeah well it just
trust me it's it's an epic cast cool
well that's all I deserve for saying
telltale games start of the segment so
don't worry about it
Alex bellos asking will players be able
to customize characters yeah absolutely
you know it's it's part part of what
makes the Lego games great you know we
want people to go make their own heroes
you know taking all the components from
from the heroes for the villains and
just make their own crazy characters
yeah assign them superpowers and and you
know effectively just create your own
superhero and multiplayer has also been
a really amazing part of these games
being able to jump in and jump out and
have fun are you guys staying the course
on that star for you doing anything new
with it and for those who haven't done
it before just going to explain where
how we'll work it you know one of the
key things about Lego video games and
the Lego Batman games is is dropping
dropout co-op two players playing
together yo being able to play a video
game with your kid that's just fun and
family friendly and and hugely enjoyable
so this game is going to be 2 player
drop-in dropout co-op you know it's got
dynamic split-screen fixed split screens
so you can pick and choose what you like
and again yeah all the gameplay hinges
around interplay between these
characters you know pick your favorite
character go and do something with them
this unique then swap to someone else
you know Batman Joker Robin Lex
yo cheater Wonder Woman there's just so
many great characters in this game
Carlton and Abhinav snella Batman is in
space does that mean that there's no
open world hob anymore so how does that
change the way in which you have these
sort of the open world stuff you had in
the last game well yeah we're going to
visit iconic locations in the hub so you
know you've got the Batcave you've got
the watchtower you've got the Hall of
Justice all of doom and as well as that
like I say you're also going to be able
to explore the lantern worlds you know
so we are going to give people that same
brilliant experience of doing crazy
missions for the more obscure characters
and races and exploring and doing stuff
in your own time we're just taking it up
to a different level you know giving
players again another new experience
Alex battle asks is there any plans for
online features in Lego Batman 3
and that's a fan of the series at the
minute what we're doing is we're
exploring what we're doing moving ahead
you know we're really focused on
delivering the best game we possibly can
for everyone like I say we want this to
be that the ultimate superhero game for
that for the whole family this year it's
coming out on next-gen consoles as well
absolutely yeah absolutely has I changed
the way in which you guys have made the
attempt you know tackle the design stuff
because these games have always really
looked great like you know they've
looked polished and I've always ran
smoothly whatever platform they were on
yeah well for us it's basically meant
that as a designer we can throw more
stuff at the screen more characters more
Lego yeah bigger vistas and and that
then is obviously meant that we've had
to develop the engine really concentrate
on pushing the boundaries which has
meant that the current gen games they've
they've gone up and if you sit them side
by side you know this game is it's just
again another step forward we put so
much work in the guys in the office
brilliant the guys and the girls put so
much work in to just push things forward
you know people are going to be able to
you know have a great experience no
matter what platform they play the game
on there's so many questions coming in
fans here Airport Ozzy is asking any
special minifigures for pre-ordering
Lego Batman 3 there is a very special
one I can't say however I saw it for the
first time the other day and I was like
yep love it yeah how close you guys from
launch we're coming up for so you know
there's this there's not long not long
but you know we are really enjoying
development some of the stuff in the
game is amazing and obviously as we go
through the rest of the development if
people just like follow you know at Lego
Batman game on social media they'll see
everything you know as as we come to
announce stuff they'll see the new
things you character new world a few
features and they'll find out everything
so much stuff I want to just go out and
tell people it's like but this is the
first some pieces of first hands-on yeah
the game was only announced recently
yeah so it's like here's the first look
and as we go through the stuff in this
game is just amazingly brilliant you
guys seem to really have this formula
down at travelers tales I don't I even
hate seeing the word formula because it
makes the 10 formulaic
and you guys have been building on it
for so long
and do you ever do ever miss making
other types of games or are you happy
creating
so cuz now we're on the third Batman
there's so many Star Wars ones as well
as Indiana Jones you've done so many is
there ever a part of you guys that
wishes you could try something else or
are you happy making this series
speaking personally like I didn't even
know someone someone actually messaged
me and told me yesterday was my 15th
anniversary teasing really okay 15 years
long time but every day I go into work
I'm excited yeah I never get tired and
that's probably the answer to the
question yeah and that the whole team
yeah we have we have a load of really
talented people they all come in every
day is different you're working on like
the biggest properties you can who can't
be excited about working on like a
Batman Lego Batman video game yeah
it's Lego Batman yeah I love Lego as a
kid I loved making Lego video games um
and you know you see the joy on on kids
faces when they ban adults actually you
know you see there's joy in the faces
when they play these games and that's
enough that to me is like yep doing a
great thing we'll keep doing what we're
doing we love it was the lego movie a
pleasant surprise because it was I was
surprising how great it was I couldn't
believe it I loved it I went actually
twice to the cinema yeah I took my
daughter Lily and me and how we just
real laughing all the way through it was
like it was one of those movies where
you thought yeah I'm gonna have a laugh
but then you got to the point most like
no that's that's hurting my job go just
back there yeah it was it was such a
good movie yeah it was wicked and the
video game was great because that was
our other office in whilmsley the fusion
guys they did a great job and I enjoyed
playing that one because obviously we
work on different ones yeah so you know
when when we finished mine it's like
I'll go and play catch up we've got the
other guys doing so but I loved what I
loved about that movie is that I felt
that whoever had worked on it that at
least someone there had played these
games because the humor that you guys
have always bought into these I feel
that it was representative there I don't
think eautiful as well yeah you looked
at it and it was just you could always
grab the leg oh it's so good right the
Parsons telltale games
travelers tail games I was white no I
was waiting to see if you do it again
apologize okay um
Lego Batman 3 wins it out and could you
name every single platform that it's
coming out have a go so it's coming out
on ps4 ps3 xbox 360 xbox one pc mac 3ds
PS Vita and Wii U and it's coming out
for this year and everyone should get it
cuz it's amazing I threw a pro thank you
very much is that hope you have your
grade III and we're gonna be back here
in the GameSpot stage with the order
1866 we're gonna check in on Super Smash
Brothers Brawl first